So, we said earlier that Grant spends the
same amount of money every month, which
means that the total amount of money that
he spent will increase incrementally as
each month goes by. We know then at the
total amount of money spent can't just be
equal to the money spent each month Our
answer down here has to involve time too.
For example, after one year Grant will
have spent way more money than he had
after just one month of being in business.
So that means that this first answer right
here can't be right, because it doesn't
involve time. However since we know that
the same amount of money is spent each
month, the second trace rate one here is
the correct one. It says that the total
amount of money spent after a certain
amount of time is equal to the money spent
each month times the number of months that
have gone by. These 2 bottom answers don't
involve the amount of money that Grant is
spending, so we can just eliminate them
also for good measure. Great job on this
quiz.